Fox News national security strategist
Sebastian Gorka conservative commentator
Monica Crowley trial attorney Rebecca
Rose woodland where do we start Rebecca
well I mean there are so many people
every day there are more with Charlie
Rose at least he was fired today at
least he admitted he did these things so
these victims are not further victimized
by the press and people who just keep
insisting that all these women are lying
there can't be this many women lying it
can't be a whole group of people
throughout the course of America who are
lying it's not possible it doesn't make
sense we are in this moment now Shawn
because for decades this kind of horrid
behavior has been covered up excused and
accepted and so now with the Harvey
Weinstein piece in the New York Times
opened the floodgate and that's why you
have now this explosion of stories
people feel empowered to come out and
tell their stories but here's the the
interesting thing this kind of horrid
behavior if you look at politics for
example goes back to JFK Ted Kennedy
Lyndon Johnson but in the modern day
Kennedy who left the the Lion of the
Senate that left a woman killed the
bottom of a body of water
he went home told nobody there was a
house across the street and he was so
beloved lionize but in the modern era a
lot of people are putting the current
marker at Bill Clinton and his behavior
because he was excused by the woman who
was the most powerful and influential in
the country not just in his life but
mrs. Clinton so there's a special place
in hell Sean for the women who have
covered fuss kind of be listen to what I
said about John Conyers I don't never
like the thing that John Conyers ever
said politically we're on opposite sides
John Conyers says no others say it
didn't happen
I believe Clarence Thomas was smeared at
the last minute you see October Surprise
after October Surprise whether it's a
DUI for George Bush or at an allegation
in a campaign 30 days out of an election
sometimes it's not true what do we do
how should people act when one side says
it happened and without smearing them
like the Clintons did for 30 years
and and take their allegation seriously
especially in the case of well is it
pedophilia we need to find out we need
to know we needed every case to know the
truth but how do you balance that and I
don't get to sebastian or MIT well this
is this is the issue now as Conyers were
bringing up a huge issue in Congress my
right to give him the presumption of
innocence absolutely not that that I'm
wrong no you're absolutely right I'm
sorry absolutely right to do it as
you've done it across the over the last
week I think you should that I've done
up my whole career Rebecca well I'm
saying of with all these victims we've
discussed this over and over I mean
that's what the Constitution provides I
absolutely
the problem with Congress is there's not
a body that is investigating carefully
distinctively and without some sort of
there's a whole shadow over this office
of compliance that that women have to go
to it's not only women men as well have
to go to if they were harassed and this
office of compliance is shrouded in
secrecy so there might be a way for with
all of these complaints now to
restructure that a better place for
people we are gonna have a coming to
Jesus moment I think in the end as a
father I have three sisters dr. Gorka
just the people that admitted these
things and groping Franklin with Franken
with his stupid with what he did too
poorly aunt Whedon is enough you know
but it was conservatives that were out
there on the front line saying wow all
of these women and there was more
besides Juanita and Kathleen and Paula
and Monica there are a lot of other
women involved in this too that I
interviewed over the years how do you
balance that and how much damage the
Liberals do in terms of their they want
the mantle that they are the great
protectors of women's rights but yet
they were involved in protecting the
Clintons all those decades now that's
the real question so you've been very
very righteous in terms of giving the
question of the reasonable doubt the
idea that you have to prove the case of
the presumption of innocence
whether it's judge Moore whether it's
John Collier Conyers but let's step back
and let's talk about that bigger issue
the left as a whole has no vision and no
morals they are spiritually and
politically bankrupt Shawn why because
they made this all possible
whether it was covering for Ted Kennedy
whether it was covering for Bill Clinton
they've created this mantra for 30 years
it's just sex it's okay it's private
don't worry about it
this created a culture of permissiveness
as a result with the political side of
the aisle that says we are for women
we support the victims they have
completely hollowed out their own moral
standing and I want to see a reckoning
right now I want to see the real
feminists get out on the street I don't
care what kind of hat they're wearing
but I want them to protest because hey
we're the right they hate us
I get it but they made this possible on
their own side let's talk about Charlie
Rose Charlie Rose let me ask Monica this
question what convince me is right from
the get-go with the Clintons Jennifer
flowers had tapes they actually said Lou
you doctored the tapes I don't know if
that you could hear it was his voice you
can hear an intimate conversation that
was was going on there but they still
went out the night late years later he
had to admit it yeah they go on sensual
relationship though Shawn with Jennifer
flood that different very different
agreed but he's still lied yes okay and
that was part of it and the wit and she
was smeared and she was telling the
truth that's the difference you know in
the case of how much will science now
play a role one of the things I thought
in the Roy Moore case for example as I
talked to a 42-year expert in
handwriting analysis said you give him
those 42 years it's an art it's a
science and he's gonna be able to tell
you forensically if the ink is new or
old and forensically if he could look at
his handwriting at the time with that
yearbook there's their answer right and
these investigations should go on
because nobody should be smeared in this
way if the charges are false problem is
here time is is of the essence right
there's an
another point about hypocrisy that I
want to make Shawn over these last
couple of decades every Republican
that's been embroiled in some sort of
sex scandal the left has piled on
because they're saying they used to say
that conservative ran is a Family Values
candidate or a family value have no
standards so they're better off but the
left is is equally as hypocritical in
this sense where they position
themselves as big champions of women and
yet in their private lives what's coming
to light now is that they're really
gonna rule against women has been
absolutely atrocious closing remarks dr.
Gork well we'll go to you first I think
this is just the tip of the iceberg
Shawn I think we have to you know strap
on our seat belts and hold tight because
I think this is the beginning of an
avalanche and I hope it means that the
left will have to clean house no more
double standards no more playing the
victim card and protected them through
2016 you know the only reason they're
the only reason that they're doing it
now is because they don't need the
Clintons anymore Koreans can't do
anything for them anymore all right
sorry Rebecca less work I think I agree
with dr. korkor this is the beginning of
an avalanche and I think it's a great
opportunity for us to change values in
this country and to change the way we
treat victims and how we handle it
totally agree yeah and we have to be
careful though this is a dangerous
territory just a word of warning this
kind of behavior has no political or
particle you're gonna have oh yeah so
well you know a lot of these
perpetrators and imprinted errs are on
the left look it could be a big
conservative tomorrow so let's just
resign or let the people of Minnesota
design well the people of Minnesota
should decide to ask the people of Vail
Alabama should decide who should decide
in Franklin's case with the picture you
have evidence I think Al Franken should
resign himself take himself out yeah oh
absolutely without a question for doubt
the proofs there he's admitted it it's
not it's not hearsay we have the proof
all right thank you all for being with
us